okay well i was just going to let me
just introduce you
to one second um from uh university of
washington
and uh i guess she is going to stay with
uh so she's going to tell us about joint
work with john
howe and robin kothari and i'll let you
say that
okay um yeah thanks to the organizers
for inviting me
um i'm going to be talking about this
work um that i did this past summer
while i was at
microsoft quantum um there is not
yet it's not yet on archives but if
anybody's
uh yeah but if you want a copy before
an exclusive pre-release copy feel free
to email me
um okay and the topic of this
talk is the problem of hamiltonian
learning
so the setup here is that we have an n
cubit hamiltonian
and then we assume that it's l local and
in some ambient dimension d
um and these are both constants
d and l so we don't have to worry about
them um
you don't have to worry about them if
you don't want to and
um here um
our hamiltonian h is a sort of linear
combination
of terms where the coefficients are
valued between -1 and 1
and the terms are just basically they're
just local terms
so they're operators on and qubits that
have support that's most l and have
operator norm at most one
um so in the example here right
just for the sake of um being really
explicit
here i'm working in a for this example
i'm in a one-dimensional
one-dimensional space because all of the
cupids are in a line
and the terms are all acting
on adjacent qubits so here
um like the e2 term is basically
something that looks like the identity
here
and then some operator on these two
qubits and then you tensor the identity
on all the other qubits
um and
um this this operator here can be
anything
but we're just going to assume that we
can write it in the poly basis and so we
assume that these
um eas are distinct products of polys so
for example this could be like a you can
see tensor y or something
so just sorry just a quick question to
clarify d so d is a
spatial dimension so d is one is a line
these two is a grid
if it's not for a moment i thought it's
cubic dimension okay thanks
yeah um it's it's it's a spatial
dimension
um okay and not allowing
you're not allowing sums of the same of
tensor products of different parties on
the same
couple of qubits um i am
so so er okay so um i just want the eas
to be distinct
um does that make sense yeah okay
um so um
for so okay given all this information
um we can define the give state at an uh
inverse temperature beta to be this
quantity here this
uh row and i'm going to think about it
as like a function of the coefficients
so as a function of the lambda
um and this is what i've written here x
the exponential of minus beta h just
normalized by the partition function
which is the trace of that to make it a
density matrix
and so the problem is that we assume
that we can prepare copies of the skip
state
and this can uh and
we assume that this we have some system
maybe like in the lab or something
that we can prepare the copies of a give
state um for just by
i don't know i don't know how physicist
physician physicists do things but
um presumably you
have some system and then you um let it
equalize at a certain temperature
stabilizes a certain temperature and
then you get some gib state
and the goal is to sort of learn the
hamiltonian from this so you
um know the eas and then the goal is to
learn the lambdas the coefficients
and these terms that uh sort of the
what we the things that we care about
are both the sample complexity
so the number of copies of the gibbs
state that we use as well as the time
complexity
which is the time it takes to compute
the coefficients after we're given
the um the the
all the all of our samples and something
to note is that
this problem is going to be hard as we
take beta i'm going to zero and as beta
going to infinity
because as we take beta going to zero
then the skip state becomes
the maxilline mixed state so we lose
information
or it gets harder and harder to learn
the coefficient information in that
respect
and similarly as we take beta going to
infinity this converges to just the
ground state
um so it can be converges to the ground
state of the hamiltonian and this
also is um uh makes
it makes it not uh makes it
not possible to get the information of
the coefficients again
um and so something to note is that
um the the time complexity here
um the best thing the best result at the
time plus can b
is the optimal sample complexity times
um the length
or times n which is the length of the
the
any a sample so if you have a sample
complexity of
um s then the optimal time
if the optimal time sample complexity is
like s and optimal time complexity
is going to be like n times s um
because you have to read all of your
input in order to um
get in order to output the coefficients
um so i have a question also in the
regime when beta is infinity uh if the
task was let's say given a given a
ground state output one of the
hamiltonians of which it's the ground
state
could that be easy potentially um
i don't know enough about this i i was
sort of hesitating i wasn't sure
what the right statement is in this
respect um
yeah um if somebody else knows the
answer
um feel free to chime in um
okay any other questions before i move
on
okay so um
another reason why we would study this
hamiltonian learning problem apart from
it being
like a pretty natural problem in the
quantum setting is that this is also
well studied in the classical setting
which i'll get to in a little bit
um and so we sort of know the the right
bounds or the right sample velocity and
time complexity in the classical setting
so here um here in particular
are the sample collectivities and time
complexity of of
um of hamiltonian learning if you assume
that the hamiltonian is classical
um and you see that as beta goes to zero
and as beta goes to infinity
you do have um that this blows up
and similarly there is a sample
complexity lower bound it's
for like a slightly different problem um
but this is sort of um this sort of
suggests
that the sample collects the upper bound
and the time what's the upper bound are
both optimal
so um we understand what happens in the
classical setting
um there's a recent work um by these
four
authors here um that's in nature physics
that
um that tackles this problem in the
quantum setting
and then provides some a
sample collectively upper bound and
lower bound which i've
given here and um they don't give a time
complexity upper bound so it's not known
whether you can
solve hamiltonian learning in polynomial
time in in general
um but they do give a an algorithm
they do sort of assert an algorithm that
runs um
if you assume that the inputs um that
that beta
is is bounded so this is the um
high temperature regime and so here
we're assumed
that this so we assume that beta is
bounded by some critical temperature
beta c and um
they they don't give an explicit run
time but i'll just uh
um just naively um how i got this was
just by taking the sample complexity
and then just assuming that the time
complexity must be
larger than the sample complexity of
their algorithm
and then here this exponential goes away
because
beta is bound and here
so here c c prime and c double prime are
all just constants that are
greater than zero um
okay so given that uh it seems like
based on the difference between quantum
and classical that there could be still
gaps
left in all three of these um in all
three of these
uh i guess problems or in these
complexities
can i ask a question i'm a bit confused
by the parameters so for example the
classical upper bound um
if i just take beta equals one so so
what does it mean
it means that using uh log n
samples from some from some distribution
so the gibbs distribution
for your you can recover the whole
hamiltonian um
yes um
okay so this distribution is very very
um
concentrated or sorry um each sample i
can see that each sample gives you
n bits or something so it's not it's
it's
information theoretically it's possible
i'm going to explain how you get this
upper bound it's
straightforward yeah
for the quantum time upper bound what if
you take beta go to infinity which is a
at the low temperature limit if this
problem becomes
simple no so so this only holds if you
take beta
bounded yeah sorry so this is like
we're trying to be efficient here
with the labeling but yeah
um okay right so
that's the state of the world um
this is the state of the world and then
um
what i'm going to talk about is our work
that sort of
closes this question in the high
temperature case
so um we
take this um sample collection lower
around in the classical setting
and then we um extend it to this problem
so
we translate it to this hamiltonian
learning problem and then we show that
we get a sample quickly lower bound
and then we show that it's tight in the
low temperature case
and also we give a an algorithm that
gives optimal sample complexity
um and so
yeah so the the only thing that's not
optimized is that the the critical
temperature
is is constant but it's it's not like we
don't try to optimize it
okay um so first i'm going to talk about
the classical setting
um so i'm going to talk about how we get
these
sample collection up around in the
algorithm
so in the classical setting
what the task becomes is um
is the task of learning the parameters
of a markov random field
so so right so what we
do is to get the classical setting we
restrict to diagonal hamiltonians h
so in particular um we have just
products of values that are z's and i's
um and then in this case the gibb state
is also diagonal
um and so the density matrix of the
gibbs state is diagonal
and so the give state is just a sample
from a classical probability
distribution
and this probability distribution if you
have if you if the give state
if you're looking at a given state is
called the markov random field
um it's just like it's the definition of
such a thing
and in particular for for the prefer for
the ease of exposition i'm just going to
consider the
icing model um so here
we have some graph um or i guess a
lattice here in in
in two dimensions and what we do is we
just
um take terms to be um
so one of these edges represents a term
that's just
z on the adjacent cubits um
and in this setting it's easy to see
like if um you could just
work it out that if you reparameterize
the base of states as plus and minus one
then the probability distribution of the
gibbs state follows this
distribution um
and so here the goal becomes we have
we're given a bunch of samples
of this probability distribution and our
goal is to measure the lambdas
um and as i might suggest from the name
mark of random field
these um these gift states satisfy
something called the markov property in
the classical setting
um which i've uh which i've described
here
so the idea is that if we have some some
subset of the space here it's just one
cubit
and i condition on all of its neighbors
so
here i've just conditioned on these
these neighbors being
plus one or minus one um
in and upon doing so um the distribution
sort of splits
into or decomposes so that the blue
qubits here are independent of
the cupid that we um are looking at so
the this pink qubit here
um and this is this is easy to see
because
um you can just write this probability
um distribution as the product of
the product of terms that don't have
anything to do
with the particular cupid i that we were
considering
and the rest of the cupid's and you can
see that if you set all of these
if you set all these neighbors to either
plus one or minus one
then just naturally it's decomposed into
a product
that depends on x i and a product that
don't doesn't depend on x i
and so this is how you would see this
um now given this markup property it's a
very strong property because it just
allows you to solve
hamiltonian learning um in the classical
setting
and so what you would do is if you
wanted to learn some lambda i j what you
would do is you would get get a bunch of
copies
of your of your row so here i have one
one sample one copy of robe and i'll
get a bunch of samples and then what
i'll do is i'll condition
so i want to learn lambda i j so i'll
condition on all of
the adjacent bits to
i and j and i'll condition on them being
one
and when i do this
um when i condition on these both being
one
what i'm doing is i'm just selecting the
samples where they match
that they're both plus one
and upon doing that then the resulting
distributions on the pink cupids
and the blue qubits are independent
and this is important because what i've
done is i've just separated
a constant sized subsystem from
potentially a large
rest of the space and so at this point
what all i only need to do is i need i
can just
learn this distribution
and it needs some working out that i'm
not going to explain
but once you have this constant size
subsystem the problem becomes
basically um it's just it's just a
calculation to show that
um you can this number of samples
suffices
to learn lambda i j to sufficient um
to excellent error as desired
um right so
um yeah
and and the reason that we only need log
m
copies here is that we can reuse samples
and then after we
we can perform the same algorithm to
learn all the lambdas
with the same cop same same samples and
then we can just take a union bound to
make sure that the the
probability that all of them are right
is is small
so i'm not going to explain the details
but
are there any questions about how you
get the classical
learning how you solve this classically
okay um
[Music]
so um now i'm going to discuss how we
just how we um
get our uh results in the quantum high
temperature setting
um so the problem that we immediately
run into if we
try to do this quantum hamiltonian
learning
problem is that we would want to try to
generalize the approach that i just
sketched before
where we use the markov property to
restrict to a constant size subspace
subsystem
but the issue is that the markov
property doesn't hold for general
hamiltonians
now luckily we have decided that we're
going to restrict to a setting
which the high temperature setting where
approximate version an approximate
version of the marker property does hold
so in particular i'm pulling from this
work of
kuahara kato and pandao
and so here's the the so there so the
strict generalization is a
bound on the conditional mutual
information um but the bound that's more
useful for
um the hamiltonian learning problem is
is um
this one this one about effective
hamiltonians
um so it's maybe
um if the experts can probably
understand
what's going on here but just um
the way that you should interpret this
bound is it means that what you can do
is that um in the high temperature
setting
you can take if you wanted to learn a
term that's supported on a
then what you can do is you can take a
ball around it
that's the size um log one over epsilon
or like
a constant times log one over epsilon
and then what you do is you just ignore
everything outside of this ball
and just pretend that your give state
that you were given was just
a union b and then once you
have this a union b then you can try to
learn the hamiltonian
term related to a and at that point the
hamiltonian term
that you get is actually going to be
close to the hamiltonian term
um of the global um the whole state
or the original gibbs state and so
basically what this does is um
just using this as like the black box it
allows you to restrict your subsystem
that's uh in the same way that you would
in the classical setting
however the issue is that this um
this ball could be as large as like log
one over epsilon two the
size of the spatial dimension so it
could be log one or reps on to the d
um and this is not small enough to just
do something like
um state tomography or something to
learn this a union b state it's it's
sort of not small enough for our
purposes
so it can give you a quasi-polynomial
time algorithm but it doesn't suffice in
general
it doesn't spice for anything polynomial
so um what we do is we
look a little bit closer at what's going
on and in particular
what we're going to use is that this
fact
that if we know these marginals
um which is um
sort of i guess the expectation of an
observable here
so this is trace e a row of x where eas
are the terms of the hamiltonian
if we know these values these marginals
then
um it determines the value of the
coefficients
um and so
this is sort of a fact that's um related
to
um related to the fact that gibbs states
um are the maximum entropy state that
preserves the marginal so basically like
you can write an optimization problem
where rho
is just something that depends on the
marginals so it's sort of related to
this notion
um and
so given this um
one can sort of think of the idea that
okay so
these these marginals are actually easy
to estimate
right because all you need to do is you
need to just measure row in the right
eigen basis and this gives you a random
variable that can estimate this trace
so we can actually get estimates of
these easily
and however the thing that we want
lambda a
it is a function of these um
these marginals and so maybe there's
some way of getting us
taking estimates of the marginals and
then deducing estimates of the
coefficients
now the thing that one we need to check
in order for this strategy to hold
is that if you get some estimates like
say get something close to the right
marginals then you can also
deduce something close to the right
coefficients right so this is what i've
written here it's
it's a lipschitz bound essentially um
so i say that like um we would need that
if our marginals are close for some
lambda that's
close to our uh for some lambda that's
um
then this this lambda till is going to
be close
um to the actual coefficient um
and i guess like
um the way to
sort of get uh manipulate this to what
we want is that
this is sort of so it's a physicist to
show this to get like an
a sample complexity pound and what this
basically
what what some something else that
suffices is to show that this map
that takes the um
this map from the marginals
to the coefficients
you want to show that this has like
bounded um
found a derivative but here it's a
vector-valued function so it's bound to
jacobian
something so it's a little bit weird yet
having this map from the
marginal to the coefficients so instead
we can analyze the map from the
coefficients
to the marginals
and then show that the corresponding
jacobian
um has sort of lower bounded is lower
bounded
so this is a um i think an equivalent
statement
maybe maybe just implies
um or in other words
that the jacobian inverse is bounded
so all this is just just to say that the
thing that we ultimately would want
is that i'm using just standard calculus
that
um we just want a bound on the inverse
of the jacobian
of the map from the coefficients of the
terms
and this is like this can be made
precise
um and this is essentially what
um this aiks paper proves
although they do it in a different norm
and then they call it proving strong
concavity of the log partition function
but this is essentially what's going on
are there any questions
okay
so um so from what i've just stated all
it basically boils down to
is just um
considering this map that takes the
coefficients to the marginals
um and trying to bound
um some like some function of its
of its derivative
okay and so
what we do now from here is that we can
use the
sort of structural results used to
achieve this other markov
markov property approximations and
instead use it to try to
try to understand how the terms and the
marginals relate
and we use this
argument known as cluster expansion and
uh what this cluster expansion argument
just says is that
if you take the log partition function
which i've written here
and then you write its multivariate
taylor series expansion
which i've written here although i
haven't defined this notation but it's
fine
um that this taylor series expansion
converges
for um for in the high temperature
regime
and upon knowing that this has a has
like a
this log partition function has some can
be written as like some power series
then we can write our marginals also in
terms of this power series because it's
just a derivative of the log partition
function
so it's it's a rescaled derivative and
so this means that we can write
the marginal in terms of
a in terms of basically just like a
taylor series expansion
and in fact the coefficients of this
these polynomials are things that we can
compute
and so now this is nice because we just
have a system of polynomial equations
we reduce this this problem to
a system of polynomial equations where
on the on one side
there are the things that we can
estimate and on the other side they're
the things that we want to
find um so here i've just written like
the first two terms
of the of the sum but it also goes to
you know um but um
they're also high order terms as well in
in the lambdas
um okay
now moving from here
it's useful to think about um sort of
the limiting regime as beta goes to zero
and as beta goes to zero in fact you
know we can
we can sort of stop thinking about all
these terms and then we just have that
if we have
these if we can estimate these um
these marginals then we can estimate the
term then we then the terms are just
the marginals like over beta so all that
we need
to get estimates sort of intuitively is
just to estimate all the marginals to
beta epsilon error
and then just divide by beta to get the
lambdas to epsilon error
and this gives you the right sample
capacity bound
so so this is sort of the idea
and more formally we do
show we do use this to show um the
desired
bound on the jacobian that gives us a
sample complexity
um that gives us the optimal sample
flexity upper bound
and um the reason why this is true is
that if you just look at the jacobian
the way that it's uh um what it is is
it's just
beta times the identity plus some
beta squared terms beta squared order
terms so if you just
make beta sufficiently small then the
first term dominates
and then we get that that the jacobian
sort of behaves
like beta times the identity in the
sense that its inverse is not too large
um so i've shown that
because we were able to express our
marginal as like a
polynomial equation i guess as of this
moment of power series
um that gives us a sample complexity
bound that we want
to get the time complexity bound we do
something basically pretty similar
which is that we have we
we first of all we estimate all of our
marginals to beta epsilon error
as we suggested in the beta 2 0 limiting
case
and and then after we perform this
quantum
portion then all that we need to do is
is a classical algorithm
and the goal of this classical algorithm
is to find an x
a a set of coefficients such that this
approximation is satisfied so
we want to find an x such that um
basically the marginals match except
instead of the marginals
we write the marginals as a power series
and we truncate the power series to
um this a frac m which is like
something like log one over epsilon
so we truncate this and now that now we
just have a polynomial and we just want
to find some x such that this polynomial
is close to the estimates that we found
from the quantum part
and through this series of
approximations
this shows that the marginals
corresponding to the coefficients lambda
match to the marginals corresponding to
the coefficients of x
and as we discussed earlier because we
proved this jacobian bound this will
give you that lambda
and x are close enough so this is sort
of like
a sketch of how the analysis would work
um and something to note is that when we
truncate at
this point this is uh basically a
refinement of what we were doing before
when we were truncating to a log one
over epsilon size ball
around a particular term so this is sort
of the same thing
um right
[Music]
um okay
so equivalently right so so now
these are just um this is just a problem
of solving a system of polynomial
equations
so the way that we do this is we just
rewrite it so that
the goal is to find an x such that
f of x is small where
f x is just comes from the difference of
these two terms so we want
basically the difference to be small and
then this is just the problem of finding
zeros or i guess uh like roots so we
just use a root finding
the the newton's method for root finding
um which is just an optimization method
that that gives you the right answer in
like log one over beta
epsilon iterations
um so
i guess i'm out of time so i'll stop
here um
i can discuss if you'd like why why this
why the result that we get is optimal or
some of these other
um pieces of the of the table if you
want but
um thank you
do we have time for questions
if we just speak up or type it
hi even i wanted to ask a question uh on
the quantum part when you are estimating
all these uh
all these uh expectation values are you
using something like this uh classical
shadow automography
results or or how do you do that wait
sorry can you say it again
so like you described your algorithm and
you said that
you just need to like uh estimate all
these uh
expectation values for these local
observables which was multimeter terms
that you can do it with logan samples
times it's like polynomial beta epsilon
and they're like do you need to use any
of these like classical tomography
techniques or or how do you do that
so um you don't need to do
any sort of shadow tomography
um all that you need to do is just to
um so whenever you
um i guess try to
uh you whenever you have a sample you
can reuse that sample
for like um a fraction of
and many different um terms
um just because you can find
you can find a bunch of terms that have
sort of disjoint support
and then you can use a one sample to
find
uh to sort of count as an estimator for
all of these different terms because
you're measuring different parts of the
space
in order to get um get these these
expectation
values um
and so you don't need to use any sort of
any
anything fancy make sense
yeah thanks
i have a question um so uh
i don't know if you mentioned this
during the talk but uh does your method
also give
a strong bound a good bound on strong
convexity of log partition function
at high temperatures
um i believe it does i believe the
strong convexity
is so i guess we don't we don't
currently have it
we don't we currently don't state that
we have it um
but essentially when i what i wrote here
um this bound here um
it's it shouldn't be too hard to adapt
this to show that the same thing holds
for the
or i don't know if it directly implies
um
this the strong convexity bound but
i think it just i think the same
analysis gives you it gives you gives
you it
but i would need to check or you would
expect two over beta to be the i
got it yeah
so since you offered maybe i can ask so
the
lower bounds they're based on what are
they based on
so um
these lower bounds are fairly
straightforward
um so i guess this this classical one
and
our work are both a classical
hamiltonians
and and so these are just samples from
probability distributions and so
um what it is is it's basically
the i believe the
the hamiltonian basically looks
something like um
maybe like 1 plus epsilon 1 minus
epsilon
and then minus 2 or something like this
like so this would be your hamiltonian
um
and then when you take beta to be large
um these
it's it's um so you would need to
distinguish which one is which so
so there's maybe i guess two options
right
you need to distinguish these two
hamiltonians
and
um because you have this term that's
um sort of the the
large portion of your magnitude you're
very rarely going to see either of these
in a sample um and so basically
this gives you one of the cases where
it's like the the um
it gives you some like the epsilon the e
to the two beta
over epsilon squared and then you can do
the other direction where you have
um the uh
and then you just you um there's a i
guess a different case for the um
one over beta squared epsilon squared um
and and at that point you use
um i guess i think it's thanos
inequality you use some information
theory to just
extend it to um to the case where you
have n copies of the state
um so it's it's um
i guess it's like yeah fairly standard
stuff yeah
um yeah sorry
so i have a question about the uh
solving the polynomial equations
um so you use this like newton-raphson
method
uh how do you know that um
yeah how do you know that it will
converge i mean this might be a basic
like optimization question but how do
you know that you'll find a solution in
a certain amount of time
um so
you can show that it converges if you
have a
bound on um
sort of the second order terms of the of
um so like
um if you if you have a a good bound on
the
um on the derivatives
of the polynomial of the system of
polynomials
then this means that you the the the
newton's method will converge
um and
i didn't this i didn't discuss this at
all
um but your polynomials
this polynomial expression obeys nice
properties because um
um sort of from the fact that
the taylor sw the corresponding taylor
series converges these polynomials have
sufficiently nice properties
that it that you can show that these
um sort of higher order derivatives are
bounded
and is this where the jacobian the
bounded jacobian inverse also comes in
or
uh that's something separate right so
this is
this isn't actually the structure of the
analysis we just sort of directly
show that it gets you um
a lamb it gives you a value of x that's
close to the right coefficients
um but yes we do we use uh the bound on
the jacobian
or i guess we use a bound on the the
the derivative after the jacobian i
don't know what that one's called
we'll use those bounds
well thanks
even i have one more question regarding
so you you motivated your talk with us
with some recent results of
of uh brandow and
kotaro and some third author
and uh and so i i was wondering if
but later it seemed that you didn't use
that result like it seemed that it's
like a
first attempt but it kind of motivates
intuitively what you are doing makes
sense but then it seems that in your
in your algorithm analysis you actually
didn't use this
this
is is that true so
we basically use
kind of this at the same or a similar
analysis
so um so sort of the
um one of one of the key ideas of this
work is using this cluster
expansion thing that i mentioned which
is
um i guess it comes from a paper
of i think it comes from a paper of
kawahara and saito
um so
um so basically we use a similar
analysis we just try to
change it to get um a hamiltonian
learning result
um yeah so
yeah yeah so you use the analysis rather
than they read that
right right
would you know if these techniques could
go to low temperatures
um or something else that could be
different producers
um so
i don't think so because um this like
multivariate taylor series expansion
stuff immediately breaks
um yeah the one thing that's nice about
this these results is that it doesn't
actually require
low spatial dimension um it requires
sort of a slightly different thing but
it's it's sort of more general
um a more general statement um
but i guess it's like not uh
yeah um it's not the generalization that
is like the best for us but um you know
it's something
any more questions
okay if there's no question let's uh
let's uh thank uh irwin
for a talk again and um
so i think the plan now is that we have
a short uh break half an hour
um people can go and get coffee or um
dinner if they're in
in europe like me um and then we resume
in uh
in in half an hour at um 11 45 is that
11 45 yeah okay good so 11 45.
the zoom is the same so you're welcome
to stay um and uh we just resume okay
have a good break